okay welcome to the wildlife in a galaxy
far far away panel here at forcefest
um real quick fourth best is raising
money for make a wish so you can donate
via the link in the chat or if you're on
git vocal here
there's a blue diamond up in the top of
your screen and uh git vocal will match
33
of donations made there so all right
we're going to start right away
i am uh melissa miller i'm a scientist
and science writer at scripps
institution of oceanography
i'm a lifelong star wars fan child of
the 80s
there we go figure this out tell the 80s
um don't actually remember the first
time i saw the movies i was so young
and just been really excited about them
my whole life i've
some articles for star wars insider
about the natural history of animals in
the star wars universe
so i'm going to ask our panelists to
introduce themselves and
talk about their connection to star wars
and also a memorable critter
for them from the star wars universe
mine is porgs
that's the one that really got me most
interested in connecting star wars to my
science background
and that's one of the articles i've
written for star wars insider was
um you know porgs are nesting on the
ground like they're shown in the movie
what does that say about them it shows
there's not natural predators
to be worried about or that they're
really aggressive and that's why they
have those teeth so
little things like that really got me
into it so um all right let's start with
frank
all right my name is frank santana and
i'm a herpetologist
at the san diego natural history museum
and i've always been interested in the
little creatures from star wars i
remember when i was a kid
rewinding the scene from return of the
jedi when that creature
outside of jabba's palace snags a little
small mammal or something and what it
looks like so we'd
watch it and ask my dad to rewind it
over and over again and i later found
out that it's called a wart
and um just kind of that it has
characteristics just like a real life
amphibian
and i study amphibians so it's it's my
big connection and
i just love all the creative and cool
creatures that are often inspired by
real life creatures here on earth so
happy to be here
great thanks angela
hey everybody uh yup so i'm angela
zamplis i'm a phd student at scripps
institution of oceanography
i primarily study polar science and with
a particular interest in
astrobiology and the potential for life
in space
so to do that we kind of look at
extremophiles which are organisms that
live in extreme conditions
uh so you know a lot of that in star
wars
ice planets i'm going to be talking a
little bit about roth
my favorite creature is the taunton and
those guys rely
off of ice algae which i study now so
cool connection i was also in
uh melissa's star wars insider
magazine article um talking about again
you know kind of cool relationships
between what we see on earth in extreme
environments and what we see in star
wars
universe it's very cool yeah so that is
coming on the next issue of star wars
insider but it's been delayed so any day
now hopefully
um okay let's get carol and you need
carol and jake to hop into spots too
sorry angela okay and tracy
ziggerman i'm an ecologist i've been
working in the fields of
mostly restoration ecology and
vegetation management
and my uh my specialty is plant ecology
um i have been a star wars fan since i
was eight years old in 1977 and i've
just always appreciated the
the little little critters in the
backgrounds and the peripheries of the
scenes in star wars it just adds so much
richness
and interest to that universe and uh
say the the creature that intrigues me
the most is the zillow beast because
i'm kind of fascinated by animals that
seem to have some connection to the
force
and zillow beast obviously can sense the
dark side of the force given his
fascination with uh palpatine
right okay so tracy you're welcome to
stay on screen here um
uh terrell can you introduce yourself oh
well i'm delighted to be here
my name is terrell whitlach and i was
the principal creature designer for star
wars the paper menace
also for the remastered versions of
the original trilogy and let's see
i've worked also physically imagineering
for doing future work for the theme
parks and other lucasfilm
projects as as well and i guess my
my favorite creature is asando aqua
monster because she
is like absolutely huge she's the
biggest preacher i ever designed
and i enjoyed i enjoyed
her a lot so great and jake
last but not least hi i'm uh david
and i have uh been working on all the
new
sequels and is a creature and
droid designer for the cfx creature
effects department
uh i designed uh cd8 called
and theo among many other things
uh as far as star wars goes and uh
inspirational uh creatures i loved i
think
as a kid the tournament like angela
to me was fantastic because it was
so believable you know you've got a
combination of like a
kangaroo and uh ram
and combined with that one and then they
kind of splice it open with their
lightsaber and his guts go out i mean
you know the little kid that's just
so cool it's very disgusting and yeah
it's so believable
out of this extra layer of reality
killing out and uh saving luke's life
there we yeah are great
so my first question is gonna be for our
uh concept artists
uh about uh what tracy i believe
mentioned
in terms of having those wildlife uh and
those creatures sort of fill out the
universe
even if they're not you know essential
to the plot so can you talk a little bit
about
uh terrell um working with george lucas
and what that meant
um for him and then jake uh you can add
how jj and ryan you know sort of
continued that tradition
well um working with george lucas the
objective was to make
all the world's um star wars seem to be
a place that we could all
go to and visit and so on an intuitive
level
they had to be related to what we
experienced here in planet earth
and on planet earth we have many
different types of ecosystems
and many many many hundreds of thousands
of niches
for biological creatures within those
ecosystems
and so the world of star wars had to
um reflect that the galaxy star wars had
reflects that reflect that
so you have obviously just like
you know there's like celebrity
creatures like bonfas
or opc kettlers or whatever but then you
have a lot
of other creatures that are there in the
periphery that are just as present
and so we went over the top to create
many many many
um ancillary creatures so that it would
feel like a
living and lush world
to be in
great yeah i realize i'm going to
present here i have some of the concept
arts carol that uh you sent me and some
from jake as well that
i'll try to pull up when it's relevant
so you can really see from these phantom
menace ones
um you know just how how lived in these
universes are even when it's just you
know
uh pigeons up on the roof equivalent
here
so so jake how did that continue into
the sequels
uh yeah similarly there was always this
sort of like i think
from every director whether we succeeded
to do it or not
certainly they you know they would they
wanted to sort of have this uh
little cutaway they call it throwaway
moment where you cut away to some
little bit of wildlife just to sort of
add
i think there's that layer of
believability and reality to that planet
and you're not
you know for a split second you're not
focusing on on the uh
the heroes and you're just
and yeah we did that with the steel
pecking bird when rey is on her way back
to
nema outpost and you see this sort of
momentum
flash of this bird here just pecking
away at some metal
they didn't matter it's somehow um
adapted
to uh the the director survive on the
wreckage that's um
the oar and the minerals that it can
find and
even the pork with ryan you know they
were there i think i've said this before
people might know this that they exist
purely because of the
uh the location kelly michael was a
a uh a world i call them what is that
it's they're protected they protect all
the puffins there so they can't really
get rid of all the puffins and a lot of
puffins flying around and and ryan
wanted to sort of uh
justify their existence because you
might see them in the background flying
and
certainly doing in some of the wide
shots and he thought well let's get a
little
you know alien version uh that we can
just
dot around in the background and they
kind of in the end made it a little bit
more
foreground than originally intended um
um so yeah there was it was again those
little nods to reality without them
being sort of
the main stars
um that wasn't in the movie
that one always cracked me up jake
you know i showed i i very reluctantly
shared that
with on you know the very first meeting
i had it was like
that was a script moment but it wasn't
they found that yeah they were gonna
find it i thought i'd take a little bit
too far and see
the aftermath the potential for what
could have gone wrong at that moment
right so um
so jake and terrell how much did you
consider the
um adaptation of the environment that
the animal was going to be
in um in terms of uh
you know your designs how much did the
environment that the animal was gonna be
in
did you study you know animals here on
earth and their adaptations or did you
just kind of use your science fiction
artistic license to uh do all sorts of
fun things
i would say that um at least for myself
and working on the foundation the
earlier prequels
uh that the environment regardless of
what planet it was
was very present the environment was
just
as about as much of a character as the
characters
themselves and the environment dictated
the type of creatures that were designed
for them
the creatures were designed for the
environment
and not the environment for the
creatures uh
and so that was something that was very
i was very cognizant of
um my own background is vertebrate is
vertebrate zoology and so that was
always
going on my in my brain okay how we have
this world
how can an organism not only survive in
the world but
thrive in the world and what how would
its design
enable it to do that just like in real
life animals and organisms we have here
that was always in my mind
uh yeah i mean i think
you put my hand up and say i'm the least
scientific uh person
in this group everyone else is far more
qualified than i am
and i certainly i'm awake you know i
have a sort of
you know an interest in science a
certain level of natural history
and yes you apply i said you look at the
environment you apply what you know
about
terrestrial environments uh you know
desert
desert things are gonna create certain
things
um jungles are going to do something
else based on what you know from reality
and i think
it's that those little things that
newly ordered from earth those
terrestrial hooks
that make those aliens
believable you know we could come up
with some crazy stuff which is like
beyond
well you know so beyond
things you can comprehend you know crazy
dogs but it
was just like a crazy star trek feature
really estimating
a lot more sort of science fiction um
i think there's a lot of science
involved
well yeah you talked to jake about um
designing
for ones you knew were gonna be
practical practically rendered versus uh
cgi so can you talk a little bit about
that
uh i'll just keep going um yeah
remix was very practical he was a very
big desire
from the directors
who will push practical events and
achieve
as much as you did in camera um
you know original trilogy has been
you know from topics or stop motion
and we tried to do that and sort of
especially the times
may have had to sort of like
for instance this horse which is the
space forces
even though we ended due to the time
restrictions we would have
actually done them
uh if the shooting schedule hadn't
changed and so a lot of the design
elements to begin with were orientated
say like the nostrils
so we made a lot of concessions to uh
practical uh requirements
so yeah the designs were
was that true for you at all on the
sequels carol is most of that
oh definitely um in fact george felt
very strongly about mixing it up
um cg and platform effects because if
it's
entirely cg you start to get into that
uncanny valley
feeling but you can mix it up with
practical
um effects where you're using real light
and such bouncing off objects then that
that can blend into the sense of reality
so yes indeed
mixing it up with practical end and
digital was the way to go and
and actually the slide that you're
showing now
with catwall um he was a
very much a practical effect
and uh he was one of the creatures that
was designed for the revamping of the
cantina scene
and that you only see his head in the
movie but his entire body as you can see
was also designed because you never know
when you might have needed to use it
so indeed absolutely
all right so i think i'm going to have
the other scientists uh switch on so
carol and jake if you don't mind uh
giving frank and angela your spots for a
little bit but do raise your hand
in the comments if you have something to
add and we'll get you back on
okay so um angela why don't you tell us
a little bit about the extremophiles
um both here on earth and in the star
wars universe
yeah uh cool stuff uh
it was it was really great seeing all
the concept art um so of course
you know looking through uh all the
movies um
you know as as someone who looks in uh
for you know life in space
um it's it's really cool seeing all the
little neat adaptations
um that that terrell and jake have come
up with um
first of all so like the the minox uh
we've got a picture of those there those
are really impressive
right um so these guys are in the uh
empire strikes back and
when they land um on the asteroid uh
which turns out to be the mouth of the
uh exagorth they find these minox that
are eating electricity from their ships
um that was actually that's actually a
thing on earth
not necessarily by animals but a lot of
these
really space-like creatures we find on
earth um
are are mainly microbes um but that is
actually a thing on earth
uh are there um are there things that
eat electricity on earth and yes
uh bacteria so they're they're
electricity eating bacteria
and these bacteria have completely gone
they've lost all necessity for food they
get their energy directly from the
source
so they have these little wire-like
threads right so there's an example of a
geo-vactor bacteria
it's got these little uh like wire-like
threads
and they take uh electrons from the
environment
so for example wherever you find these
geobacters sometimes they're in mud
sometimes they're in the deep sea
if you stick an electrode an electric
current
uh with an electrode into that area
these bacteria will colonize that
electrode because they are getting their
nutrients straight from or they're
getting their energy straight from this
electrode
um so that's really cool so these minox
um going back they have
uh even in their mouths they're kind of
thread like um and then they go
to ships and they steal the electricity
from the ships
which is really really cool you know
it's these electric
bacteria were discovered in 1988 when
was empire strikes back
uh that would have been 80. 80. uh
so well ahead of its time you know uh
very very cool stuff
um you know with with you know crazy
organisms
um you know again star wars well ahead
of its time we discover these things
later and we're like oh wow how cool you
know
um what else yeah so the
the exogorth itself right so lives in an
asteroid
lives inside rock right um so again you
know as scientists we know that there
are
um things that you know bacteria that
live inside
rock to guard themselves from solar
radiation or dehydration right they can
keep the moisture in they can guard
themselves from
solar radiation and radiation in general
so that's already really cool
um what else so both these things were
supposed to be silica based
life forms um that's another cool thing
in astrobiology
there's you know when you're
hypothesizing other forms of life
right so we are all carbon-based life
forms on earth
everybody is their primary uh primary
composition is carbon
right um but there's you know when
you're hypothesizing other life on earth
you can think of
silica based silicon based life forms
we we are all carbon based on earth
however there are some organisms that
incorporate
silicon into their lifestyle such as
these diatoms melissa has on these
screens so
these organisms incorporate
silica into their shells so they have a
glass leg protector
over their bodies which is really cool
so diatoms are these little
phytoplankton
um they can also live in ice um so one
of my favorite creatures i mentioned at
the beginning is a tauntan
and i really appreciate you know that
again the artists
thought about you know in terrell's book
um it talks about all about how the
tauntons survive
off of primary producers like ice algae
um and again we find algae living in ice
and that was recently
i mean that was discovered fairly
recently you know like what is all this
brown goop and the ice and art
um turns out they're live algae right
living in the
ice um which is really cool which
sustain ecosystems
so it's really cool that again terrell's
mentioned that in her book you know kind
of
when you look at a whole world not just
the animal but then
you know a little bit about the
ecosystem or what it lives off of and
it's cool to you know see on roth the
ice planet
um that they've mentioned these plants
and algae that live in the ice because
that that is the thing on earth as well
um a lot of cool extremophiles living in
places that we
you know approach the near limits of
life itself which is
really cool stuff yeah as you can see
angela was a great expert
for me to talk to about the um star wars
insider article where we also talked
about
the per gills from star wars rebels and
also
that large uh octopus-like uh thing out
in space
in solo so um all these animals that
live out in the vacuum of space
um yeah opening the priggles in the chat
i thought that was called
the whales that float through space said
it right yeah
part whale part uh part um
squid or something so yeah um cool
uh frank i'll have you if you want to
talk about the reptile and amphibian
analogs
in star wars sure you want to start with
the warts
yeah all right
so the warts um in terrell's book that
she wrote on the wildlife of star wars
which is a great
field book that she was co-author on it
describes them
as being amphibious and
you know just kind of having explosive
breeding so whenever there's a rainfall
event on tatooine it's probably a
short-lived kind of thing
so they actually will go out and lay
their eggs and reproduce
and their little tadpoles have to grow
and
develop very very quickly and that's
really similar to a real-life frog
that lives in the american southwest
which is the spade foot frog here
and if you look at this species it's so
wild looking right looks like it could
be something from one of the star wars
movies
look at those eyes and the little orange
spots
and they have a lot of the same
characterizations and features that
the warts have um they have uh
these events where when it rains in the
wintertime here it's only like a short
period of rain
and they actually live underground most
of their life
and they're buried underground and they
are surrounded by the sack
so they have a mucus sac that covers
their whole body
to protect them from drying out from
desiccating in the dry time
so 10 months out of the year they're
just underground waiting for the rain to
fall
and when they feel the rainfall they can
actually burrow up above the ground
come up and find these temporary pools
and reproduce really quickly
so they're very similar to the biology
and natural history of the warts which
have a
very similar um life history
and they're also endangered right so a
lot of these animals that are inspiring
um you know artists like terrell and
jake
to kind of come up with these sketches
on earth
are sometimes endangered so it's another
kind of link and important message for
us to try to protect the real-life
wildlife as well
um and then next would be uh another
cool amphibian so that's kind of my
background is studying
endangered amphibians so whenever i see
amphibians in the
star wars universe it gets me really
excited and this is
none other than the child
otherwise known as baby yoda consuming
or trying to consume a frog and if you
remember from the season one of the
mandalorian he consumed
um two frogs the first frog he actually
swallowed and
ate it and that that frog was like a
brownish color and if you look at this
frog
you see some kind of bright colors on
the legs right so what do you think that
might be signaling if
a frog or any other organism might have
some bright colors
so it's probably a signal that it's
poisonous and that's
what real world frogs on earth here
these are the adelopus
genus of frogs found in panama
so central america and south america
they're really critically endangered
look how amazing and beautiful these
colors are
so they're active during the day they'll
be out in the middle of a stream
where there's a high risk of
encountering predators but because they
have these bright colors
um it protects them against predation
you look at these like they
look like they really did inspire the
artists that made the
color scheme on that frog that baby yoda
was swallowing if you go back to that
he actually spit it up and you know the
little kids were kind of looking at him
like telling him not to swallow it but i
really think that baby yoda spit it up
because it tasted bad
so it was probably poisonous and it
probably had some nasty secretions on
its skin
and so i wouldn't have eaten it either
he probably had a good tasting frog the
first time
the second time he's like no this does
not taste right
so he spit it up so that that poisonous
uh
signal is true to that color scheme um
so protected the frog from
from dying in it to see another day so
it's pretty great
um and then tracy we know in the star
wars universe that there are a whole lot
of planets with one ecosystem like you
mentioned
uh forest moons and ice planets what how
would that lead to
uh adaptations on those planets
well even even planets that have
like a homogeneous homogenous ecosystem
would have
um changes to their its environmental
conditions over time and that's really
kind of what drives evolution is uh
changes that are driven by geologic
events or
changing weather patterns things like
that so
they that would that would constantly be
um changing you know habitats some
habitats would would expand
some would be lost new niches was open
um
species would either adapt to those or
die out
um and but what given my background in
in work
spending so many years working in
damaged ecosystems my first thought is
that how many of these planets
are actually in their pristine state
um and how many have had some sort of in
outside influences from all the
interstellar
travel um and what species have been
introduced
um that have changed the population
dynamics
of the creatures that that were native
there
um and i that's that's a really
fascinating aspect to me
because uh you know i've dealt with with
invasive species
of plants in my career and uh they
really can
thoroughly transform uh an ecosystem
to the detriment of everything that was
that was originally there
so they can be that can be a driver of
evolution too
all the influences of of off-world
introductions um and then you know of
course the development that that
inevitably happens
when when uh off-worlders come and start
exploiting the resources and so forth
um some have some habitats are are
damaged
um you know pollution changes
changes the the atmosphere um so all
those are drivers of evolution as well
and uh it's really fascinated me that
that because i in browsing through
terrell's book um so many of the
creatures
and we see this in the you know in the
films too so many of the creatures have
adaptations that that make them
even if they're even if they're lower on
the food chain you know they're not
necessarily predators
they had to have adaptations that that
defensive adaptations that make them
look really fierce
and that kind of leads me to think that
that
life is really a struggle for all of
these
these creatures on these worlds that
they've had to
adapt tusks and uh you know claws
and and all sorts of things that that uh
um
we don't really normally see on like
herbivores here
in you know on earth um
so i find that really fascinating too to
think about
um what what they've what those life is
like
um in the struggle for survival on these
planets
yeah carol do you want to hop in and i
know in your book there's some mention
of the
invasive species minox is one we've
already talked about
grabbing onto ships and and going from
planet to planet that's something that i
work in oceanography and that's
something we have to be
concerned with in terms of ballast water
moving animals from place to place and
them taking over
so uh tracy you can stay on if you want
i've got more questions for you
well as far as invasive species goes i
you know in the world of star wars
everybody is
always traveling there's spaceships that
can go everywhere and so of course
the people are going to bring pets with
them they're going to bring
livestock they're going to bring
unintended um
uh what do i say um
animal species that sneak on you know
how rats and such sneak on or whatever
by by design or accident or
some some some species are brought
intentionally
some accidentally and so you see all
this
seeding of these planets
um for example the raincores aren't
native to tatooine they come from
somewhere else and um
so but there are you know people
associating with tattooing because of
that one particular
poor lonely rancor that just happens to
be you know a slave to java
uh and then of course there's some funny
things like
in um you know courthouse and where you
get
dianagas in the sewer system and they oh
hello when next time you want to use
one of the most fascinating chapters of
that book was the coruscant wildlife
so you have a lot of in those urban
areas you have a lot of
imports you know and maybe species that
were taken to zoos i mean
i would assume that we have zoos here
and there's always escapees
and such um so
i think that's fascinating and yeah
there you go um
in coruscant we have all kinds of
animals you have wampas and corazons
at the poles you've got um
things that are in hiding in the alleys
that will eat you
uh angela if you don't mind trading out
with jake i'd love to hear his thoughts
on porg infestation
now that oh can you hear me
oh there we go okay she's back
drop it up here
here okay
you guys can hear me yeah okay uh i was
just going to say if angela or
jake you want to grab that spot i'm
interested to hear about uh what you
think of
chewbacca taking orgs off of aku
well all right i'll go ahead and tracy
if you want to pop in here
but i think it's bad yeah i'm picturing
porg investigations everywhere
serious tribbles
yeah there was a little porg infestation
i mean yeah
chewie took one adoptable
i think you saw one another one making a
little nest
uh in the bull walk
waiting to hatch
now across the galaxy uh at least the
start
that you know has begun
unleashed yes well and i know you said
that's a steel
steel pecking bird is clearly you know
adapted to
a different environment probably than
than originally
so that's something that you considered
in some of your designs for the
inhabited planet
or other things well if there were other
ones
but i remember you mentioned that
i've always assumed that that must have
got something
you know rust and i don't know unless
somebody else
maybe carol's already explained it
until that was uh explained um
eastern which has been completely
and it will be made to adapt in another
way
yeah um so can your and your feeling
tracy is dagobah like one
untouched planet i know we don't see
most much of it but it seems very wild
to me
yeah it does it seems like like that
might be
um one of the you know one of the few
remaining
sort of pristine undisturbed planets
there which kind of leads you to
leads me to think why um what is it
about
the is it the is it the atmosphere
that's so hard to fly through
that disables ships um you know what
what it is about that
planet because it's obviously rich in
resources
but yet it's been left alone um
to kind of look pretty much like a
natural ecosystem
um another one that comes to mind is and
i don't know that i can't remember the
name of it but the
the planet that um yoda visits
um in the uh uh lost missions of the
clone wars
where the three he encounters the three
force priestesses
um that's another one that looks um
fairly undisturbed and and that one's
obviously because it's
that planet is sort of hidden i think he
had you know had to have special
knowledge to get to that place so
yeah it makes one wonder how many how
many worlds you know would be that way
in such a gala in a galaxy where where
you know space travel has been um the
case for
you know perhaps millennia i mean the
jedi talk about going back a thousand
generations so
i'm assuming they had space travel all
that time um to be the guardians of
peace and justice throughout the galaxy
so there's been
there's been some influences on all
these planets um for quite some time
yeah jake if you don't mind switching
out with frank i know he had some
thoughts about dagobah
thanks everyone
yeah it seems like dagobah has some
great biodiversity as tracy was talking
about you know how it looks really
pristine there's so many different
species that we see there
um so it's kind of cool to see you know
so many different varieties of creatures
and
a lot of them actually reflect real
world creatures so if you look at the
scenes and the empire strikes back when
in yoda's hut if you look at that photo
there that scene
from um luke first getting into yoda's
hut
he's kind of impatient and angry and he
sees this snake
there and he kind of just picks it up
and tosses it aside and
if you recognize that snake it's
actually a california king snake
so it's a species of snake that's native
in the in
you know in california here um so it's
kind of cool to see that overlap
and there's a lot of other species like
monitor lizards and other
real-life animals that were roaming
around on the set and it just kind of
adds a level of kind of biodiversity and
realism
to that scene which is so so cool and a
fun little tidbit is that when luke was
actually
working um on the set he got bit when uh
mark hamill was
looking he got bit by a snake at one
point and
that obviously didn't make it into the
movie but it's a cool little
little thing you can look up on youtube
luke skywalker bit by snake
and yeah and looks like yoda or r2d2 is
in the back scanning the biodiversity
making sure that
looks safe or something so right
worrying outside the window
um tara i'm curious oh tracy have
something to share
yeah i just this this uh this
this so is i this is my favorite page
two pages in the book
actually because um this is the shows
the
the the varying layers of life in degema
dagaba from ground level going up into
the canopy and this
this mirrors so well what we see in our
own
uh rainforest both tropical and
temperate it's just
it's really cool i really like that
cheryl it's awesome
thank you animals are so fascinating
very hard i think that goes back to what
tara was saying about the niches right
you when you have a vertebrate
biology background and yeah how you made
all these niches so that's such a cool
concept well thank you
yeah it was a fun one to do that you
see pages someone in the chat mentioned
naboo
as well and i'm curious since that's my
favorite
probably planet uh since i'm into marine
science i'm curious carol about
your um your you know
experience getting to getting to flesh
that
the boo though as you take that plant as
a whole is just so
um so biologically
lush and so rich um anywhere from
the swamp um swamp creatures
to the planes beautiful green planes
to obviously the deep um
the atmosphere depths of
the going through the core of the planet
so that was just
like this whole like noah's ark full of
delight to
to do and i think part of it is that i'm
half floridian in the part of florida
where my roots are
are the springs in the panhandle and so
there's a lot of
cool swamps and cool creatures and
alligators snapping turtles
and alligators and big huge roaches
it's pretty amazing um and then i live
presently i live in the willamette
valley in oregon
we have this it's like the new zealand
of north america this lush
green and then going to the ocean
beautiful sheer cliffs and we have a
trio of
live volcanoes and it's beautiful
um so all of that
all of all those ecosystems i kind of
put into
naboo and there's that fascination with
bioluminescent fish and such that live
in the depths of the ocean
um and there was a place where i could
really explore
extremes um and beauty at the same time
so often
we become space space creatures or
science fiction creatures as being like
full of hard surfaces or scoots and
horns and such but this was a chance
to really create some animals that were
rather while they were odd they were
exotically
you know beautiful too and so that was
that was fun
um as far as
the depths of the
core um ocean i would guess you'd say
the inner ocean
uh that was fun in that these the three
the three big um predators
uh were very diverse um the
the first one was a little chimera
because i think i mentioned in an
earlier meeting
that it was kind of an angler
presentation combo
but it was fun you know it was it was a
fun yeah the opc killer and that was
actually originally a doug
chang design and then i worked on the
anatomy and such
and then the claw fish was like you know
kind of
wary eel black swallower and crocodile
and then the aqua sandal mounts too is
actually
more of a i would say a repto but
mammal basically and that had a lot of
mammalian anatomy in it it did have
gills but the animal absolutely also has
lungs which is very adaptable
animal that can go all the way from the
depths to the surface of the swamp
because it eats anything and that was
actually that animal that inspired
the earth animal inspired the aquasonda
monster as a tiger
that's the animal that i was i always
had in mind was a tiger
especially particularly the tiger from
the apocalypse now
like what is that thank you
thanks for having that book uh yeah and
i love
she included little skin parasites on
the
knife yeah i mean basically each time it
was
create a creature that could eat
godzilla for lunch
hey frank if you don't mind switching
out with jake i was going to ask him
about his marine creatures too
so i know in acto there was some fish
uh and i was gonna ask him about that if
he's still around
um there we go
let's see if he's able to join us jake i
remember you saying that fists are
basically aliens to you
anyway so how did that influence you
designing
well they they're the marine animals
fish are just the hardest alien
you know i think ryan wanted some fish
for luke and patch and carrie
and i think the the caretaker we're
going to cut some up
we were going to have a fish market at
one point in solo
i thought we ever made it but again we
made lots of fish
and in both of those cases when the
directors have said
i want some cool alien fish it's
impossible it's just so hard because
fish is the most all marine creatures
not necessarily fish specifically
but just the thing you know
quite regularly i'm watching the news
and they'll say oh we've been down on my
on a trench or something you know
very deep exploration we found this
music
mind-blowingly bizarre alien
is very very i found it very hard to
come up with something
that is you know it doesn't just look
like a crazy fish
from a radius um yeah there are some
these are they're getting
the uh these were early uh was it the
sea cow ideas which were a bit easier
i have to say but fish the fuji getting
fishy i find it very hard
so well done terrell for her take and
her what she managed to do
[Music]
well amanda had a question in the chat
that goes into one i was going to ask
anyway in terms of domestication
so in um empire we've got the
tauntauns uh on hoth that are
domesticated
um there's also all sorts of other
beasts burdened the dewbacks the bantas
um so i'm curious for carol and jake how
it was different
um designing the creatures that the
main characters were going to sort of
utilize versus just the
sort of in the background wildlife
okay so um you know the animals
like um the what the
gundams are writing and also like
the eops and the like um right
exactly yeah well um
for example the eops would be sort of
camel analogues
they were basically camel and logs and
you know it's funny i'm having a brain
for use right now i mean
put on all these characters but
um and sometimes the names start to meld
after a while the animals that
the gungans are riding um
there's um fondas and then there's ah
that's
the the two-legged ones um those are
ostrich and dinosaur analogs and
basically could this animal carry
someone you know a humanoid writer
could or other types of loads easily
how similar is that to what animals are
already used
um here on earth with hamilton horses or
yaks
or elephants and so those are things
that i kept in mind that way
yeah jake you have a a bunch i'm showing
here some of your concept art from solo
i believe
it's gonna be a bigger mind sequence and
a possibility
you know a beast to sort of partly
uh aged only mining uh
blacks against the sort of mishmash of
uh tech technology and
a giant beef again i said already that
you know a lot of our stuff
is is practically driven and what the
luggage beast is driven by you know the
war horse
puppeteering principle uh the big beast
which is just one above you
in the luggage in that slideshow which
you saw on
on that one again that's warhorse
technology taken to the next level uh
where we had a
five couple years uh creating it i've
totally forgotten the thread of this
question because i'm now talking
about practical effects and not biology
um domestication yeah i mean again
you just try and find things that you
recognize this we did
various different versions of the big
beast and we settled on something with
pig like
these guys showed up in in persona on
in in the last divisive skywalker
i know they were they were originally
this was going to be in person we used
it in tatooine it was just
one of those things but again it was
finding something
camel right you know we wanted to find
something that was you
think that's a bit like a camel it's a
bit like a giraffe you sort of latch
onto it
um you knew that they were practically
able to do the things that
camels and giraffes would be camels
could do with you
but then you just throw in you know oh i
want to get this is just me going off
i'll give it some finishes like an ant
uh and then maybe it has to be
i don't know it doesn't have a mouth and
teeth it has much more
uh it kind of grinds it up to these
pinches
just because it looks cool really i mean
i don't really get into it
i just trying to find something that
looks relatable
uh to something you recognize
and combining it with something else
um but i would say the other sort of
beast of burden like the horses
were really based you know it was like
the banter in
in the original uh the ot
in star wars was an elephant and i think
everyone would love being able to use
practical solutions where possible so
you know they had to be like horses but
again these were a horse these were
horses they we
dressed these up they've got giant you
know the only reason they've got these
big bug eyes
these are the all backs are real from
solo
uh they've got these big uh compound
eyes
simply because the horses need big sort
of orifices
to see through comfortably without
getting spooked
so we gave them a bigger
hole to look through those are just back
painted pieces of plastic
they can see perfectly clearly through
them and have no obstructions
but it was kind of hey this is you know
cool we've given us a very
mammalian uh beast
uh compound eyes which i don't know i've
probably got against some entire
terrestrial biological wall or something
broken everything
um nonetheless
i own two horses i have owned a dressage
prospect and then i have my schoolmaster
horse who's very forgiving for me and
and what you're saying makes
makes a lot of sense you're gonna have
one horse and
working she's very green so she's in the
in the fundamentals of her training and
she's got a fly mask as well and then
i've got my schoolmaster
i just i call him my schoolmaster
because he's very forgiving
um but what you're saying is very true
and uh it's interesting to see how much
a horse will tolerate
as far as costuming and putting
acroments on them i mean the very fact
that they allow
bridles and saddles and awesome things
like that
in history they've worn you know armor
and
all sorts of dressier in their whole
armor and livery and everything like
that so they're quite they're quite
amenable
but there's things like they hate that
they need their ears to be sort of
quite mobile they need a nice space
around their eyes
they need a certain amount so you have
to make these concessions so
i've learned about horses
well we're gonna start wrapping up we've
got about 10 minutes left
um i want to ask all of my panelists
if there are and also everyone watching
feel free to comment um what your what
animal in the star wars universe you
most want to know more about
and so for me that is the rancor um i
know that
terrell book i also read the jabba's
palace book
when i was younger um and got really
fascinated by the idea that the rancor
was essentially a pet
um and you see that a little bit in
return the jedi with the keeper you know
crying when it's killed
um and that made me think about pets in
the star wars universe and if jake is
still there maybe he can talk a little
bit about that
um and then we'll just go through the
panelists real quick of what animal
even those of you who designed them what
what animals you want to know more about
just uh having not seen enough screen
time
so jake i know you put a couple of pets
in the casino scene
a strange dog i think you see it very
very briefly
um which is i i had it sort of with this
little inflatable
kind of um abdomen where it would you
know
my idea was that somehow it had some gas
this is it
i it sort of filled it it happened with
some lighter than air
gas i don't know how um i sort of
thought oh maybe it could live in a sort
of gas giant even though that doesn't
really make sense but
it lives in the air it floats around it
would have given the fact it had four
legs i made the rear legs for the
vestigial
like they sort of rolled away which kind
of suggested at one point there was some
land for it to walk on
so the gas giant thing was maybe not
but yeah it just paddles its way through
the atmosphere
um and it's now become this sort of
little pet
dog to this lady uh became somebody
else's this lady
she lost out and then there was another
dog we had which i didn't design
on the next slide down which was you
could just be there being held by the
creature in the background neither of
these are my designs but they were both
designed by luke fisher
one of my colleagues and this little guy
is kind of loosely based a little homage
to
gary fisher who is carrie fisher's
always character she's
a dog and it's this little you know sort
of i think it's french bulldog or
something similar so it has some of
those characteristics
um yeah there aren't quite enough i
don't know because i know there aren't
many other pets
maybe i don't know salacious crumb
warrants being a pet
jabber or whether it's just some little
creep
um you know he is sensitive that maybe
he's not a pet
yeah yeah so do you have a favorite uh
or an animal that you would want to know
more about jake
that you want to drill down with some of
these scientists about
uh i well
in a way i'm not sure if you've already
answered this because
they've always been intrigued by the
space
slug and i cut the extra
answered a lot of those questions in the
book uh it was still
i mean it's got teeth because it's not
got teeth that you see
as it closes
why that's what i want to you know it's
got to be it must eat something
uh fleshy um i feel like i'm kind of
curious to know what it's piece or are
they just vegetables
perhaps i don't know or maybe
all right well you'll have to read my
star wars insider article coming coming
soon
so uh how about you carol
well um i'm always intrigued by some of
the
the three the creatures on the side
um the ones just just as in nature i'm
i'm
we are all seeing the lions and tigers
and they get a lot of attention but i'm
personally more fascinated in crosses
and civets and genits and
those type of predators that we don't
hear talked about too much
in the world of star wars um there is a
particular bird
called the pekopeko and you see him fly
by
very very quickly but he fulfills the
same role as say
a hornbill or you know blue high and
since macaw would in in iris i'd like to
know more about him
and then there is a creature that didn't
make into the films but didn't make it i
believe
happened to the clone wars and other
um properties and that was the zlakas
those
these alakaz live in the swamp
and they are actually terrestrial
relatives of the
sando monster they're like
kind of vicious dragon horses and i'd
like to know
you know i would like to see more like
more exploration
in those particular animals okay um
apparel and jake if you don't mind
swapping out for
frank and angela so they can give their
last uh minute
tracy uh what what about you
well as i mentioned earlier i'm i'm
pretty intrigued by
the life history of the zillow beast we
just got like a
i think a three episode introduction to
this
giant uh monster um
when uh when it was released from
hibernation by the detonation of a super
weapon
and uh we're kind of led to believe that
that this is the last in
of these individuals um but i'm you know
considering how it was found i'm always
wondering you know are there still more
buried under the surface and then that's
like what happened
on that planet to make them you know
make it
even if they're just that one make him
go into that state of hibernation like
it was a planetary catastrophe
or just you know too much too much
predation and they went into hiding or
but uh but yeah and it's it's seeming
ability
to um uh deflect
pretty much any type of weapon including
lightsabers
and uh and and does it really have an
affinity for the dark side to for the
force and especially the dark side of
the force because
once it encounters palpatine it pretty
much
focuses on him the rest of the time
that's rampaging around coruscant i mean
you see
you see there it's got a hold of his
shuttle um
so i'm wondering if it has a you know an
innate
uh affinity for uh the dark side of the
force and it's drawn to
it in an aggressive way yeah how about
you angela
uh all the space creatures of course uh
but also uh
i my one of my favorites the sarlacc um
it's it's just really neat it's also got
some like you see on an angler fish this
parasitic male
and then and then you know living over
thousands and thousands of years with
that really slow digestion
like to find out more about those
chemical properties of that acid
really neat stuff uh yeah the starlight
was kind of one of my favorites
sorry frank i didn't give you much time
but let's hear from you real quick i
want to learn more about the blurbs and
whether or not they give good hugs with
those
four loops that's great
i want to thank all my panelists uh
again forcefest is raising money for
make-a-wish so you can donate via the
link in the chat or if you're on get
vocal there's that
um blue diamond and get vocal will match
33
um thank you so much to my scientists
and to my artist i'm going to throw up a
slide real quick for a couple of seconds
maybe no um
just with all of our information on it
if you want to find us on social media
hopefully that'll stay up for at least a
couple of seconds
um and then you can get in touch with us
do you have other
in touch with us uh scientists and art
questions
and definitely check out uh terrell and
jake's instagram feeds they've got so
much of their great
concept art so if they want to hop on
and say bye that's great
um thank you so much everyone and uh
i hope to hear more from you and to get
to write more about this
so jeremy thanks for coming
yeah thank you so much for being here
i'm so glad it ended up being virtual
and thanks for forcefast uh
for putting this together so we could
still have a star wars celebration this
weekend
and making it possible for carol and
jake to join us from
um outside uh outside of southern
california
yeah thanks so much for your time
and jake and carol thank you so much for
your contributions to the star wars
universe it
is obviously all of our favorites here
in this channel
it's our pleasure thank you
all right everybody